on est toujours dans cette quête de
l'âme russe tente d'être aimé par le en
plus un très grand nombre de personnes
et que finalement la maturité
l'expérience de la vie vous apprend une
chose c'est que finalement un
la terre entière ne pourra pas vous
aimez et que d'une certaine manière il
faut se contenter de de ce qu'on a et 2
kw à 2 50 quand on dit hein il ya 1,2
pardon
oui mais le 2 décembre le job de 2 c que
la vie n'est donnée que plus belle au
niveau de mon jeu alors aujourd'hui vous
iriez boire un verre avec gérard
houllier qui vous avait descendu en 94
mais vous dites quand même j'irai boire
un verre avec lui mais bon le vert il
termine pas forcément dans la gorge non
alors j'ai là pour parler de ça parce
que je peux en parler à vos mains avec
une certaine sérénité 1 je ne vais plus
m'encombrer d'aller avec les gens je ne
vais plus m'encombrer d'aller passer du
temps avec des gens qui ne le méritent
pas ou que je n'aime pas c'est à dire
que le temps qui passe je vais le passer
avec des gens qui à mes yeux sans des
gens importants voilà c'est tout cas
c'est pato n'y a pas de deux y a pas
d'accord alors s'il ya pas deux arrêtes
de dire ça suffit maintenant
alors aujourd'hui je suis prêt
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai vous passez
des heures à admirer la montagne de la
sainte-victoire par exemple ce que vous
n'auriez jamais fait avant vous êtes
devenus plus contemplatif je les ai
toujours été voilà je peux passer des
heures au jardin regarder à regarder la
mer
je veux passer des heures à regarder la
montagne devant et je suis prêt je dis
toujours été comme contemplatif j'ai
toujours eu cette cet amour de 2,2
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux